for nearly two centuries
these hills overlooking the connecticut
river at springfield massachusetts have
been the home of the famed springfield
armory
the arsenal was deactivated by the
department of defense in april
1968. during its long and colorful
life the springfield armory turned out
more than nine million firearms of every
purpose and description
since 1795 american soldiers have been
armed with guns from the springfield
armory today
federal square as the area is known is
still the site of armaments development
and manufacture
many of the buildings have been taken
over by a large government contractor
and the production of some of this
nation's latest weapons takes place here
some of the buildings of this national
historical landmark have been given over
to the springfield technical community
college
the former headquarters of this military
post now house the dean's office and the
various administrative offices
flanking both sides of the parade ground
are the old officers quarters
which now serve as study halls for the
various technical subjects taught here
the ground in which i am walking is rich
in the history of our country
general george washington founded this
great arsenal in 1777
and later visited it during the time he
was president
well franklin d roosevelt was another of
our presidents who came here
the list of famous military leaders who
trod this green
is endless the beloved poet henry
wadsworth long fellow after a visit
composed a special poem about the
arsenal
that building was the main arsenal in
1871 the commanding officer
colonel jg benton officially created an
ordinance museum and today it occupies
all of the buildings
it is called the springfield armory
museum
and contains more than 11 000 firearms
and other weapons
gathered from every corner of the globe
it is one of the largest collections of
military arms in the world
thanks to colonel benton who lived in
that imposing home over there
we will be able to see some of the guns
which played such a vital role in the
history of our country
like the thousands who come here to find
out about the development of our
military weapons over the years
let us too see the guns at spring
at the outset of the revolutionary war
in 1776
the colonial patriots had very few
firearms
there were only a handful of gunsmiths
throughout all of new england
and work as they might they couldn't
possibly make enough weapons to arm the
continental army against british
but as we all know from our history
books
the colonists did get armed some of them
were captured from the british
others came from various foreign nations
all were crude flintlock weapons like
this early french pistol
the story of firearms development in
america is a fascinating saga of our
army's history
one of the nation's foremost authorities
on this subject is with us today
i'd like to introduce them to you tom
wall director of the springfield armory
museum
hello tom i'm delighted you could be
with us to help explain some of the
interesting background and the guns here
at the armor museum
well i'm not sure you needed me today
russell what i've seen you're really up
on the history of small lands
for instance you were talking about all
of those imported european weapons that
our forefathers used
i have one here this is the french
charlieville flintlock musket
thousands of these were imported into
the colonies from france between 1776
and 1781.
certainly it seems well made even after
all these years
did our soldiers like these guns yes
these are the finest
military weapons of the period
the hammer had a piece of flint clamped
in it and the spark to ignite the
gunpowder
was created when the flint struck an
iron plate
to load the soldier had to ram a powder
and ball charge down into the barrel
from the muzzle end of the musket he had
a ramrod which was carried in the gun
stock for that purpose
then a priming charge of powder was
poured into the pan alongside the
chamber
when this primer was ignited by the
flint spark it entered a small
touch hole and set off the main charge
what did the springfield armory have to
do about all this during the
revolutionary war i mean
well the continental army stored in
firearms and powder here
however the main purpose of the army
during this period
was the manufacture of this paper
cartridge which was used in the army
musket
it wasn't until april of 1794 that
congress enacted legislation that
established the springfield armory
and directed their weapons to be
manufactured and stored here when did
they make the first gun here at springtv
it was a flintlock musket in 1795. come
over here and i'll show you
russ this is the first official us army
weapon
patterned after the french charlieville
musket that we were just looking at
we copied the french design because of
its obvious superiority in the
revolutionary war
this is the 1795 springfield flintlock
musket
it weighed about nine pounds and was a
product of good craftsmanship
our troops used these muskets along with
some of the foreign guns still in
service
during the war of 1812 against the
british and canadians
and at the battle of tippecanoe against
the shawnee indians
well then this is the first u.s arsenal
made weapon the army used
is that right yes the gunsmiths in this
country had been making muskets for a
number of years
but they were for private individuals
and various colonial governments
i see what was the next gun that was
made here
well we had some variations in the
flintlock design
but in 1842 the big change the addition
of the percussion musket
then we added some rifling to the weapon
and this increased the accuracy and gave
us a better range
by 1861 we had the best military
shoulder weapon of the day
we've got quite a collection of them
over here
incidentally it was a display of this
type which inspired henry wadsworth
longfellow to write the poem the arsenal
springfield
before the civil war he brought his
bride here for a visit
and she remarked that these stands of
guns reminded her of a great pipe organ
i guess he was pretty impressed because
there were some 50 000 muskets stored
here at the time
and the hall was filled with racks like
this one
if you've never read the poem here's the
first stanza
this is the arsenal from floor to
ceiling
like a huge organ rise the burnished arm
but from their silent heights no anthem
feeling startled the villages with
strange alarms
henry wadsworth longfellow 1843
these are the standard model 1861 63
springfield rifle musket both sides use
these during the civil war
thousands of these were captured by the
confederates from the union forces at
the early stages of the civil war
what makes these guns so special
two things russell first the firing time
was speeded up
and the gun was made more dependable
because of this percussion system
the hammer struck this copper cap
that in turn ignited the charge in the
barrel
second the mini ball which is more
accurate than the musket ball
loaded more rapidly
despite the fact that these rifle
muskets still had to be loaded from the
muzzle end of the gun
they're a great improvement over the old
flint lines 80 percent of all the
casualties in the civil war
were caused by this weapon
the 10th massachusetts battalion of
artillery from worcester
first connecticut volunteer infantry
from south windsor and the 14th
connecticut volunteer infantry from
glastonbury
put on a demonstration of these old
weapons vote
ready for
fire
oh
thank you very much
card
the most important thing about these
guns is the fact that they were the
first
mass-produced firearms and had the
advantage of interchangeable parts
i guess the mass production scheme
changed things quite a bit here at the
armory didn't it tom
it sure did muskets had been limited in
production
up to the civil war the peace work idea
for each army employee made one specific
part
or performed a single function in the
manufacturing process
enabled the armory to put out over a
thousand muskets a day by 1864.
some 3000 employees were used on the
production lines
after the civil war the u.s cavalry had
a rough time with the indians of the
western plains tom
what was the gun they used to fight the
indians was it the same one we just seen
no by 1873 the sprinkle armory was
turning out a new breech-loading gun
designed by the master armor erskine
allen
officially the government called it the
u.s carbine model
1873 but to the technicians here
and the soldiers who used them the guns
were known as the trapdoor springfield
with the increased rate of fire and the
long range of this weapon
our troops easily gained superiority
over the indians
this was a major factor in opening the
western frontier
speaking of the cavalry russell here's a
famous revolver which was issued to all
cavalry officers in those days
yes 45 caliber peacemaker
this was one of the great handguns of
all time wasn't it
yes it was old sam cole really designed
himself a winner when he put out the six
shooters
it came in different barrel lengths and
a revolving cylinder bringing each
cartridge under the hammer
was practically foolproof as a standard
sidearm issued by the army it had no
pier
it's been almost 100 years since this
gun first appeared
today's revolvers still work on the same
principle
that's what i call a good gun design
well russell the army has always been
interested in good gun design
come over here and i'll show you an
interesting example
the 1880s two norwegians developed this
bolt-action magazine rifle
this was a great improvement over the
trapdoor system
as you can see the rifle had to be
loaded one cartridge at a time
on the other hand this norwegian design
permitted the loading of several
cartridges at one time
and to fire each one all the soldier had
to do was to work this bolt
it ejected the spent cartridge and
placed a fresh load into the chamber in
one easy motion
in 1892 the army was impressed with this
design
and paid the two norwegian inventors a
royalty of one dollar per gun
to have the springfield armory produce
the weapon for standard u s army issue
more than three hundred thousand of
these rifles were manufactured here
was the first time since the shellyville
musket that the us army had adopted a
foreign weapon for their military
service
well if i remember correctly this was
the rifle used by the us army regulars
in the spanish-american war wasn't it
that's right and in the philippine
insurrection and the box rebellion
but that brings to mind another great
weapon to revolutionize the army's
weapon system
in july of 1898 a new close support
weapon
was used against the spanish at santiago
cuba
the gatling gun invented by a doctor of
medicine
james gatling gave the american troops
superior firepower
for many years this forerunner of the
modern machine gun
was deployed only as an artillery piece
it was an army captain dan parker who
devised a way to use it as a full
support of infantry
his theories were proven at santiago and
later adopted by european tacticians
in the trenches of world war one
during this same period while our troops
were engaged in the philippine
insurrection
they requested a rapid firing handgun of
heavy caliber
in order to stop the human wave charges
of the morrows
the fierce filipino warriors would dope
themselves up
in charge in a frenzied fury our troops
needed a large bullet like this to keep
the enemy from reaching them
this is the automatic pistol that was
developed by john
m browning like the earlier colt
revolver
this is a design which has stood the
test of time
since 1911 the browning pistol has been
the us
army basic sidearm
so that brings us back to the beginning
of this century john
what happened here at springfield then
i'll show you
well russ the age between 1900 and 1936
was a great age of experimentation at
the springfield armory
this is one of the fine weapons they
developed in this period
1903 bolt action rifle as a rear leaf
site here
standard army weapon for many years
it would be safe to say that this rifle
was one of the most accurate
long-range shoulder arms ever devised
hitting targets at a thousand yards
was well within the capability of this
rifle
during world war one sergeant alvin york
received the medal of honor for his
exploits with a springfield rifle
he was an expert sniper he also captured
over a hundred of the enemy
single handed merely by threatening them
with his sprinkles
yes i remember this rifle very well
here's a converted rifle that very few
people have ever seen
the standard rifle was altered to fit
the needs in the front-line trenches of
world war one
in that type of warfare it was unsafe to
stick your head over the parapet of the
trench because some expert
shot might pick you on
the rifle was converted to lower the
butt portion of the stock
and fitted with a periscope a remote
trigger control
permitted the soldier to fire without
having to put his head up in line
with the sights it was never an army
issue
but the soldiers who converted it used
it to put effect
world war one is one of the most brutal
wars of all time
the french knives were used by our
soldiers in that war
but this was also a time when automatic
weapons were being perfected
look at these
this is the lewis machine gun it was
developed by colonel isaac lewis the us
army colonel
it was first used as a troop support
weapon but because of its lightweight
it was quickly adopted by the allied air
arms
this is the machine gun credited with
shooting down the great german zeppelins
over england
however because of this rotary drum
magazine its firepower was limited
the browning machine gun perfected by
the same man who gave us the automatic
pistol
was water cooled relatively light in
weight and his 30 caliber bullets were
fed to the firing mechanism by long
ammunition belts
more than any other weapon the machine
gun gave rise to armored warfare
of course russell the germans were not
to be outdone
this is the machine gun they used both
in the air and on the ground
it was developed by an american hiram
maxim
in the mid 1930s the world famous m1
grand
semi-automatic rifle was developed here
at the springfield armory by one of our
engineers
john grant his invention was given to
the united states government
as a gesture of mr grand's great love of
country and he never received any
royalties
nor payment of any kind his superb
design
gave this nation one of our best
individual weapons
during world war ii our soldiers fought
their way through europe and the pacific
with this weapon
general george s patton claimed the m1
garand was the finest weapon
ever used by the american army between
1940 and 1945
the springfield armory produced more
than 4 million of these rifles
thus surpassing the total output of arms
for all the years
between 1795 and 1940. and that wasn't
all u.s army troops carried the m1 right
into the korean conflict
general douglas macarthur said the m1
even outperformed the wonderful model
1903 springfield
not only for its rate of fire but for
accuracy and rugged dependability
here's something
it seems that the period from 1936 to
1957 was a very eventful 21 years in the
science of weaponry
what was semi-automatic rifles though
yes a lot of new weapons appeared during
those years and these are some good
examples
the bazooka a rocket launcher was a
revolutionary development
and was introduced in tunisia early in
world war ii
for the first time the infantry had a
shoulder weapon designed to penetrate
tank armor
um
the recoilless rifle here developed late
in world war ii
fired artillery shells and yet was light
enough to be hand carried
this is the 50 caliber browning it was
often used to shoot down enemy planes
while they were making low levels
strafing attacks upon ground troops
i know the 50 caliber machine guns are
being used by the army today
so that brings us up to the present era
of weapon development doesn't it
yes russ between 1957 and the present
time
the automatic arm has reached a high
state of perfection the sprinkle armory
played a key role in this development
soon after the fighting ended in korea
the m14 automatic rifle
became the standard army shoulder arm
replacing the m1 grand
it was capable of firing 750 rounds per
minute
and weighed approximately nine pounds
when our troops first went to vietnam
this is the weapon they carried for real
hand carried firepower however
nothing can equal the rugged m60 machine
gun
it is relatively easy to carry has a
high rate of fire
and uses ammunition in a range of
weights for good penetration of heavy
brush
and undergrowth it is one of the army's
most useful weapons
in the airborne operations in vietnam it
serves as a prime item of armament
on our assault helicopters
another special weapon was this m79
grenade launcher
it was used to reach out and hit the
enemy when he was too
far away for our soldier to throw a hand
grenade and yet
too close in to call for air support or
artillery
using big shells it loads like a shotgun
it's very effective and amazingly
accurate
the soldiers depend on this quite
frequently
and finally we have the prototype of the
m16 which is used in the jungles today
the springfield armory is no longer
making the nation's military weapons
but with the inventive genius of the
weapon developers and the productive
capabilities of the armament
manufacturers
newer and more effective small arms are
being produced all the time
among the many new weapons designed to
help our army do its job
is this rather small automatic gun
that bears a startling resemblance to
the old gatling gun
and indeed works on much the same
principle
the developers of this new weapon call
it the rapid fire
minigun watch this
almost 200 years have passed since the
colonial patriots founded this nation
through their armed rejection of british
rule
from flintlock musket the rapid fire
minigun
is a long long way
in every step the american soldier has
taken in the defense of free men
he's been armed with the finest weapons
carried by any fighting man in the world
he has been secure in the knowledge that
he would be back
in war and peace with the guns
at spring
you